at this point in early December last
year police are conducting a
missing-persons inquiry not a murder
investigation we're speaking to you
relations with disappearance of grace in
footage shown in court today they
questioned the man now accused of grace
malanez murder he gives his story that's
you walking in with a suitcase mmm at
8:14 yeah I've still got a suitcase in
my room and you guys can have it if
that's what you did you're assuming you
haven't told the truth about being
completely drunk on Saturday night maybe
I got the times wrong as to when I woke
up but I'm telling you that bag is still
in my room what's in it nothing what did
you blow it for to move all of my stuff
out of my room this is the CCTV footage
that contradicted his account the
prosecution said today it shows the
accused a 27 year old man who cannot be
named for legal reasons the day
following Miss malanez death he is
pitted not guilty to her murder
saying she died as the result of a
consensual sex act gone wrong in the
footage the defendant visits a shop just
after 8:00 a.m. on Sunday morning and
buys a large suitcase with wheels after
taking it back to the hotel where he was
living he goes to a general store and
buys cleaning products then back again
to his room two hours later the
prosecution said he goes to a car rental
store where he has a small red hatchback
the next footage is from the afternoon
that day it shows the accused arriving
at a bar for a date arranged through
tinder grates malanez body is still in
his room in court today that woman who
cannot be named gave her testimony she
said that during that two hour date
the accused told her police dogs can't
smell bodies that are buried more than
four feet in the ground later that
evening the defendant fetches a trolley
from hotel reception
and takes it back to his room he returns
with two suitcases loaded on it one of
them contained miss Mullins naked body
forced into a fetal position he has
since admitted the next morning he
buried the case in woodland outside
Oakland city center the prosecution said
a week later it was discovered by police
greats malanez parents have been present
every day of this trial as the sequence
of events was outlined today they wept
gently the trial continues Tom Cheshire
Sky News